previously on raft i want to do
something about the organization of the
chess here because it's i know it's hell
all right mark i got an inventory full
of stuff is your system ready
why are all these beats over here by the
biofuel container
we're working on it all right mises clay
you said
gazes clay and other knee looking type
things
his group was the organization working
hard
hey mark does the seagull really go into
town on your flowers
do you guys not like my organization
assistant
i love it i've got a blip for oh i got
the new island
look at this it's like civilization up
there dude there's a bicycle schlong
machine
oh but wait there's a tear deck
falcon is there something incredible on
this island that i should pay attention
to because i'm getting another
organization tactical monster near the
bicycle squad worth me stopping
organizing
is it worth it you should check it out
you should keep this
mark you should check it out you should
peep
this mark oh god was there a book oh no
that's a building
oh no i can change your signs are you
changing myself
no i would never do that
the bicycle schlong machine but be
careful
rocks are raining from the sky oh what
the hell
there it is it's a bird
yeah but it it it throws things with its
it's a bird yeah yeah i did
say to him that it was a bird and he
heard what he wanted what is here
different terrorism pterodactyl look at
it and it's rocks
i said a pterodactyl falcon parrot
because i realized
that it was a bird halfway through my
sentence
still doesn't make any sense it's not
what it is it's a
fracking excuse you
are turner ah i'm dying now on the boat
where are you oh why are these birds so
mean mark i'm getting lazy and i'm kind
of starting to ignore your organization
already is that good
so long i know you did
you did you great work buddy excellent
work really
it's so easy we're all proud of you i
don't understand what goes in knees what
doesn't go in the knees
oh there's look like knees it's simple
it's literally
bitch-ass bird dropping rocks on me i
don't like that
can you guys turn the lights back on uh
mark our potatoes knees
head or potatoes are cooked or poop
that's where potatoes go
oh oh that's poop poop is for biofuel
you can't attack the boxcar children
guys i found a kitchen on a cliff
that's kind of cool did you guys did you
guys go clinically insane as i was
organizing did something happen
while i was away you're the one who
didn't pay attention to what was
happening you
you did and pay attention to us hey bob
so it's my friend
rock explosion you can open doors in
these like little box cars and their
stuff i just want to get underneath of
oh you can oh wait i can't open doors in
the little box guard some of them
some of the things oh shooting clothes
and open the little
yeah little wachoukas and there's
washikis in there no
no mark over here come come look out the
window like it's a house and we live
together
okay oh [ __ ] oh it left wait it went is
this this way look out this
oh there's another house there man this
house sucks when we were gonna move
you said you were gonna make a life for
me look ah this is all moving way too
fast i just wanted something casual
where'd it go there was a deer up here
some sort and i spook it did you scare
it
i heard a scream i can't the bow kill
the terror bird
no no oh no look it's coming at me wait
wait honey
uh huh this is interesting we need
explosive powder
babe yes you're not looking at the
the cute where we were i see you
remember where it happened
it's a goat we need that goat we can
milk it
we can milk you oh i was going to kill
it i should not kill it how do we go
with the goat yeah yeah yeah yeah i got
it i got it we gotta milk the goat to
make our
bucket shovels for i don't know
why do we make for does goatee chicken
wing
hold on i need i can make this i can do
it i
this is my time it's almost like i was
made for this
did anybody got net we got a lot of bees
here we could get more honey squoosh
i need to make a netcast a what
i've got a net launcher but i need to i
need to get the nets that you load it
with
okay i hit the burb once do we need
explosive powder for that we might need
explosive powder for that how do you
make explosive powder i think
it might be one of those items we find
you know like because
story islands usually have items like
the tnt and that other one
ow dick oh god there's gaps
oh god there's gaps be careful on that
bridge there's gaps mind the gaps
i'm battling the burb oh it's targeting
mark no target me
why me come here you ate hole it's like
a shrimp
yeah i look that's what do you even
listen new pieces it landed
come here require kill it i will slice
your ass so hard they'll never
find it what is a zipline part and
you're gonna slice the ass into pieces
or you're gonna slice it
whatever it come here you piece of [ __ ]
come here
i killed it no i didn't i did i did it
oh
i no my heart can't take this is it dead
are there more
no that's not dead it's a real piece of
[ __ ] that's really squishy but it was
like
six arrows oh it's i think it's
targeting you right now
good thing your stupid rocks don't do
very much damage idiot
oh my god he disappeared he's a wizard
i'm scared of the bird now he's a wizard
he landed on the side of a mountain and
disappeared oh he started another wizard
i can tell you that that bird's magic
is not of this world he didn't like me
very much oh i got this head
bro oh this head broth stew is gross you
were not lying about the
the gaps in the bridge yeah watch out
for those this this
cooked chicken breast is a little too
veiny for my uh
yeah the bird does go for the boat he's
a real dick yeah i wish we had zipline
things there's so many zip lines here
yeah uh is there like a anyone see a
blueprint or something like that there's
got to be a
pretty enthralled in my bird battle
right now gotcha
idiot this is a what oh is that a
chicken
no yes no no it's dead i did it
that was really good that bird have
explosive powder in its head
i'm falling down a mountain carefully
okay
there's a lot of like chickens on this
island if we ever get the livestock up
and running
battery charger part i will kill you ooh
i got batteries
new stuff note yes
i'm just staring at this bird that i
murdered oh god
i'm having a horrible flashback i
remember something
when i was playing this before many many
another lifetime ago
i was told that in order to get
explosive powder we have to hunt for
like some really dangerous
fish in the water like a puffer fish or
something i'm pretty sure it's how we
get the explosive powders
they're only around islands there's like
one or two they're very dangerous
they're very damn what it smells like
they can like one shot kill you no joke
they like one shot kill you
but we have to kill it and get it for
the explosive powder i think
sounds like a lie i think d live told me
about it
in another life that guy lies all the
time
eli yeah eli told me but he was truth
and he was d
truth at that point i don't believe
guys i gotta never mind
it's not exciting i got something but
you won't care
try this out come on it can't be that
bad oh sure sure
now you want to hear about my day i do
yeah
why is there something killing me
probably the bird no i was bees it's
bees
there's a there's a building with a like
a tarp over it on
the far side of where i am i that's it's
probably the special buildings that we
need to get like for the
blueprints and whatnot oh i got a shovel
okay i got a shovel
oh good oh we need that yeah there's a
hole in the top there's trouble stuff
off that lamar's legumes canned goods
look at this terrible con
like convention of naming there's some
scrap metal in here with the dirt
sorry are you mocking the branding of
the peanut company in this
post-apocalyptic wasteland yes
absolutely
what we need multiple explosive powders
there's got to be some of those evil
fish in the water
we need something i there's a huge sack
that says rice on it here that i
see one oh god my ankles i see a puffer
fish
i'm afraid of it please continue
narrating your every move
where do we get zipline is the big
question
uh bobby dying if i jump will this kill
me
i'm jumping body dying
i did it what i got i got two explosive
goos
hey and i got a new head
oh thank god we have the head box and a
new nose you know what mark i
mocked you but you were right thanks man
what was i right about
that's fine it doesn't matter all right
i did something useful wow mark i'm so
thirsty
okay am i am i supposed to do something
about that mark i'm just letting you
know because i'm here now
okay i don't know when we live together
oh man this
this shark has just been taking
advantage of our
lackadaisical nature oh dear wow
it's working towards the engines great
word thank you
all my flowers oh my flowers
[Music]
good job guys we need we need swimming
equipment we got to go deep
there's so many crisis is happening
right now i can't even emotionally
handle this
oh
oh now we're getting elvis wade
elvis it's been a while since we got
elvis wade wow oh
yeah i remember now i don't like it yeah
i don't like elves
no one does
you can't just make jokes that are funny
like that
stick to the usual material god
inside somebody dry this you know what i
gotta draw i gotta
smelt the explosion i you have to put
i'm sorry you have to put the explosive
powder into the place where the fire is
well no no it's not powder now it's goo
i gotta powder the goo
oh well it's still explosive though then
no
not yet yes i don't know
it seems like yes is the word that
you're looking for who's on his boat
with me is this a good look
what look what happened to you
you've changed and why do i love it
yes oh hit him with the 360.
wow thanks for the smooches please never
do it again though
come on powder me daddy what what do you
need what what are you looking for
i'm cooking the goo explosive goo it's
cooking over here oh okay
wade's about to blow us all up okay good
i was hoping actually
i'm we we yes you know use your words
uh-huh i can't i'm too a [ __ ] sighted
oh you [ __ ] so like [ __ ] excuse me
i've got the powder if you're gonna do
that you have to at least do the rest of
the reference come on now that's the
reference i don't get it
i don't clamp blindfold
get it yeah yes white is so hard for
whatever he's doing right now
dude you have no idea my nips are in my
loins and their own
fire like that all right dirt
done mark where does feathers go
feathers
grandmother who's shocked at every new
thing she hears from a very slow
no i don't like that i don't i have
leftovers
i have a bowl of leftovers that says it
didn't turn out very well is that
that's bad this is gonna really suck
when i miss this one shot i get to take
what what are you trying to capture a
goat
ah do we have a pen for it do we need to
make a pen for it
we probably do all right cool is that my
job are you all just leaving that to
me am i do i have yes uh
i mean do you want me to be honest with
you or do you want me to say that i'm
going to help
captain i do what you say it's fine i
guess
okay let's not have that in my hands
because it will only end horribly
wait wait before you do anything let me
come watch so how do we make the pen do
you need any resources
brother mark uh pen i don't know what a
pen
even is is it just like you build some
walls and then put it there and it won't
be able to get out
i have no idea oh are you going for it
and i want to see your failure
while you do that i'm about to go on the
adventure of a lifetime
yeah oh my god oh i gotta go tonight oh
my god wait carrying a goat
you gotta go oh my god what do i do what
do i do i've gotta go i think maybe if
you just put it on the boat
it'll just it won't it can't swim maybe
it won't swim
maybe it won't swim maybe you just have
to carry the goat from here on out
that's also an option wait where'd you
go
well like where'd he goat right guys
dude why don't you mention that because
i'm gonna go jokes like that without
warning me
yeah well can i swim with a goat i mean
i hope so or else you're not getting it
onto our boat that's on the water
also if you can swim with the goat your
legs are
chunky oh yeah look at these legs
all right goodbye guys what no mark
there's a goat go by it's too late for
me where's the pen going
why i'm going because someone told me to
follow the pipe that that bike was
connected to and it just goes down
yeah that's where we need the flippers
and the oxygen i'm saying
if you see a puffer fish don't let it
touch you but kill it and get that sweet
goo the sweetest supposed to kill it
without touching it
yeah i'm just i'm gonna avoid it oh this
is terrifying i hate it
oh god it's subnautica all over again oh
god i hate it oh it just keeps going
down
i don't honestly know wade i'm gonna
look at the research thing real quick
hang on oh there's a seagull being a
real
a-hole over here oh okay this is the
worst
thing that's ever happened to a human
that's probably not true
uh there's a lot of puffers down here
no wait what did you do
i lost the goat why did you
do that oh never mind i can just pick it
up i can just hold it now but now it's
not tied up
is it is it your baby
is my i this came out of me
i don't like that that's not good i got
an infirmary key
i got a zipline part we got ziplining
overplayed well played oh good nice
oh my [ __ ] god
you okay the thing exploded
oh my god hey we have what we need to
learn about
oh god i'm not dead oh did you just
waste my puffer fish
you just shut up i am trying to survive
i don't care about your life i care
about my puffer fish
i don't care if i come home i'm going to
kill your goat i'm going to eat your
goat
don't it doesn't like hive stories
hive stories the stairs i had to climb
the stairs to put the goat
down and it won't jump off because it
doesn't like stories
explain it again i didn't get it wait i
see what you're doing here i see
hang on hang on hang on i got
i got your back sister don't even you
don't you even
i got a bowl of soup underwater
oh well you all right mark i was eating
a bowl of soup under water
it was really funny all right wait
god
we have a goat problem wade where is it
it's up by the trees for some reason
okay i'm gonna make us i'm gonna make a
goat home
a goat home yeah i'm gonna make a goat
home okay
while you do that i'm gonna go check out
the infirmary i got the key to it
all right we have a goat trapped we have
a goat how do we prisoner
i found it crop plots okay i can craft
one grass plot
oh yeah the grape put it in here put it
in here i need to get i need to find
more dirt so we need to do we have dirt
in any of your chests yeah i think it's
in knees
thank god for your organization mark can
i just say that oh look at all this dirt
dirty knees look at these you know
anything that could be associated with
knees too like dirty knees that could be
probably medical supplies for bruised
knees and scrapes and scraped knees
oh my god organization this uh i did
oh my god you're gonna have so much
grass you will never not know
what it's like to not grass little goat
soon you just provode for your goat so
aggressively
look oh my god it's so grassy can you
check the uh research table see if
uh zipline department became part of
wait did you name
this goat guys what do you want me to
see on the research table i'm looking to
see if there's zipline
tool there there's not what i found
zipline
maybe it's like the one building we went
to where like you just find the parts
and it happens
oh is it is there multiple oh it's
probably multiple parts or something
yeah because there's the only things we
can research now are healing self good
healing salve backpack
leather helmet leather body armor do i
need to shave my goat
do you shear goats no way no i'm pretty
sure your sheer
sheep also mark we can now build a metal
detector
that's where the ziploc bars are did you
shovel up here did you shovel
i shoveled by the goat let's make a
metal detector okay we need a battery
and scrap
yeah you can use a dead battery you can
use a dead battery for that
how do we charge batteries though um
don't worry about it you can make a dead
oh yeah mark we have a goat in a grass
patch oh
god that's so cute right
look at what his name is idk
it's got oh my god how do we make a
bucket can we milk it
oh [ __ ] it you could probably make the
yeah bucket
scrap rope plank i got it i bought it
don't any else do it i'm doing it
okay okay i was gonna use a cup but i
think a bucket's north yeah cup probably
wouldn't
milk it into one cup come on milk into
this cup
all right is everyone is everyone here
ready to see me milk
yeah wait do you see how pr wait mark
you did this recently you know
you're pregnant with milk the boobs are
or whatever the others
they really don't have four that i saw
but yeah go for it milk that
milk that goes and it really shrank
the boobs oh my god who needs some milk
slap it in my mouth
my stupid pee brain remembered something
what do i do with milk
milk broth fish stew you can make stews
stews blues yeah stews you make stews
you lose wow
uh anyone make a metal detector all
right uh someone with a shovel
come help me i'm gonna meddle you sh dig
i think is how it goes my flowers
stop oh we got my other flower oh no
all right i'll guard the fort since i'm
the only one who's not an
idiot i got him sorry mark but he got
you
all right wait he got me just try to
bolster my esteem
oh you might want to come with us for a
moment though if we go back up to the
goat land
uh i've got the explosive powder to put
in that big explosive keg thing
oh yeah i do want to see that oh yeah i
do want to see that oh yeah i
wanted to see that first so i also
wanted to see that yeah i don't have to
be first on one first
i said it first that i wanted to be
there first yeah but i i
i don't care about the order it's a long
time i was first that's great
and i agree there's no medal up here
no medal none of this is metal this is
it there's no metal i want a good view
of this
don't i'm coming wait hurry up hang on
wait
has been lit oh god way better hurry
wait what's gonna happen now okay i'm
here i'm hiding behind mark
okay i'm gonna get a good one
wait what
oh there's a ghost and it's floating
away there's a ghost
we probably need whatever that is go to
that island
um jump in it oh it's not water
oh my [ __ ] ankles wait oh that's not
one yeah
so how do i kill a puffer fish oh it's
looking at me
use your use your stabbies did you guys
really just jump off the mountain with
the
the shovels oh i got the shovel i jump
in the water though
the water water water water how do i fix
how do i fix puffer fish i'm dying
just don't die just be stay strong oh
i have one health did you go to the top
of this island where the
soul is that we need no i couldn't quite
figure out how to get up what if it's a
dementor just be careful it might suck
out your soul
pick up zika is it flying part is that
what it was
yeah oh we just need one more i bet i
bet i got a better
tom helmet and a zipline party i bet
it's uh has to be metal detected
wade mark wait what is this
sir what what is this what's mark mark
come on wait i just jumped off
i'm i'll come to you wait no there's a
crate no no dude there's a crate down
there
god oh okay those look crazy you see
wait bob turn around
look what i was trying to tell you about
i i mark i would have died if i landed
on that i don't have any health
what is what is this what get look this
just this major tom what is that i think
it's a space exploration thing i don't
know
you know ground control the major tom
anyway i've got a red light on i'm going
to try to find this
metal detectee so do we have more
corresponsive powder
oh no we do not cuz there's another one
right so we have to successfully kill
another blowfir
that's the thing shovel person with
shovel
yeah that's me it's me i'm the shovel
it's the thing shovel thing
okay where you set this thing i can't
get on top can you grab on my shoulders
you jump up and i'll try and shove in
under you when you get up
oh that works hey all right well i don't
have a shovel so
oh wait do you do you keep doing it yeah
and then you do it your own self nice
okay um why am i the only idiot who
can't make this happen
you hate another verse are you are you
holding anything i can can you hold some
stuff for me
sure you know biofuel and some stuff
why do you just have this there's for
chess
wait you got it all from that there's a
chess i
will never forgive you i just got it
nailed
dirt oh when you say it like that well
okay wade follow me
because i i'm i'm going for the uh
i'm here too there's a beep around here
somewhere okay we gotta go up to go
around
follow me you got it beep mind the gaps
beep beep beep beep beep three b
we got three lights over here four
lights five lights
okay six we're close oh okay
went down hi
guys mark you just ran by a raptor
pigeon i know it's like a chicken or
something i don't know
we could put that on with the goat i
know there's a summoning circle in here
is that good
oh this requires three zipline parts but
we only have two ziplining parts
well found a battery charger it's uh oh
it's up deep rip
yep wait no
[Music]
you just did it look it's it's like
right where i'm standing right where i'm
standing
are you sure it's not inside this thing
no right here it's right here just dig
right there
where's the boat there you guys there it
is
was that a was that a dig it up we do it
almost one more
there you go what'd you get uh titanium
leather
titanium that was fancy titanium cool
we've never had that have we okay oh hey
friends you're over there
yeah we're over here oh god the birds
are back
yeah fine they're no bother but we
didn't get
another zipline part wait yeah wait what
do we need to make another canister
there's a something something though
for fish i need puffer fish there's
something here i think we can capture
what yeah look at this turkey it's like
a turkey gobbling around look at this
yeah there's a little rafter pigeon look
look at him
look look no one look no one's looking i
saw it
we saw it we look now for my own
enjoyment oh
oh hey okay i'm looking where are you at
bob no i
gave up oh i don't know which way you
are is
i found that thing where we need the zip
line parts for guys yeah you already
know
already what hey look there it is bob i
see it just by you oh you're seeing it
yeah you seen it
oh yeah oh i see it
i found the world's stupidest plumbing
system
and a note are you at my house again is
it your face
oh wait was better i gotta make a trip
to the boat i want to head to the boat
as well
i found a puzzle oh that was a bold one
now ow
that was a real jump i just took there
was a bold
oh hey look at these docks we could have
yeah we could have parked over here
yeah yeah i'm about to solve a puzzle up
here
great job mark well hey
okay follow that yellow line down you
see the yellow line where the water's
doing at this thing
and uh get to the bottom there there's
like a well down there make sure the
last
piece is in the right alignment and go
down there
what if it's not a line then align it if
you can
yeah i hear solution is that you boys
i'm solution
he's just trying to get the sploosh in
the right spot there we go
okay yep yep it's in the well water is
hitting the well okay good
there's something in the well i think it
just needs to rise i can't pick it up my
inventory oh zip line part i can pick
that up
oh wait wait three or three
wait you solved it good job thanks bob
what do we do now up in the top middle
there's a thing that
will open now there's a crafty bench
where you got to put the three zipline
parts i think to make the zip line well
let's go do that
yeah yeah oh why did i
follow you i don't know
[Laughter]
you can only hold one salmon salad
salmon salad i didn't cook that for you
where'd you get that
yeah what what harlot was cooking you
salmon salad
i found it i swear this a bit's really
hard for my brain to comprehend for some
reason hang on
you oh no does she do
the thing that i won't do it that's the
one i'm gonna do the zipline thing maybe
i did the zipline thing wait i'm coming
i wanna look
too late there's a zipline tool but i
didn't have room in my inventory so i
threw it
oh
hold on
[Music]
how's the zipline you having fun yeah oh
god why am i still exploring
i have a zipline tool i mean require a
zipline tool that's literally what i
have i think you got to
put it as an equipment thing oh oh i see
oh i'm hoping that there's water over
the wait a minute
i'm trapped on the zipline oh my god
that's terrifying what
you bounce off the end yeah oh you gotta
jump on no you gotta jump off or you
just
bounce all right i like that that's kind
of cool i mean
i appreciate the real pigs
we need nets there's pigs over here i
get more puffers yeah
guys there's pigs what's up murder pigs
no wait a minute i don't know if we want
these pigs they're not very friendly
are they christ i guess uh oh there's
another literally
it turned on me stomped its foot and
then was like
i took my hand off the keyboard no i'm
dying to a pig
okay all right that's fine wait we can
research cheers battery charger
yes i got some healings to have yes
i found that titanium ingot oh mark we
need your
we need yours you need my titanium
bring your indies
[Music]
i got a mayor's chest key is that good
that sounds great i gotta know thank you
um yeah cool stuff
now if i had an extra net where would
the net go is that a toe
well net interesting i haven't set up
that place just
yet it'll be a shoulder for now in time
yes
that's good good good so i'll put the
salmon salad upstairs bob i didn't touch
it because you didn't make it
good good damn right good
i feel really bad for even touching it
should feel like a scumbag i do
there's a murder pig up here too
i found a diggy hole it's by the death
pigs mark
friend i need to ask you another
question holy frick they climb rocks
what guys consider glass glass that's
part of honey scam
is that what it's called yes mark which
one are you exploring
i'm coming back home need water all
right there's a lot of diggy holes
on the on the high part of the island
i might die i actually i i'm about to
expire from lack of thirst
from flashback lack of awareness
of thirst i've never been less thirsty
in my life
help me uh please god
if i collapse please collect my body i'm
very far
where are you i don't know i should
probably fill those up i have no idea
where i am
i'm pointing i cannot the boat is down
if you can go down oh my god
i'm going to die and i'm in the most
isolated corner
that i where am i no please not like
this
no no how did this happen
to me
i'm literally at the farthest most
isolated i was walking
it was gonna be right around the corner
please come get me
boat come to me near the main house
we're definitely gonna come get you
soon so that's for sure please
the mayor's house i don't know where
well that's where i was so all right so
you're up high
no i'm by the water line okay
good because the mayor's house is
literally at the top part
below and near the mayor's house okay
you're behind a pillar of some sort yes
okay i i fell down and it was some weird
scrap metal dilapidated area it looked
like almost like
barbed wire sussing it out it really was
very strange this place that i went to
and by the weird scrap metal
structure keep going through there
through here if you're
if you're going towards the docks it's
the wrong way so
you should i don't know where the [ __ ]
i'm going okay just keep going
no there's a back to the ghost no no no
were you by the goat no did you zipline
down mark no i jumped i was
i was stumbling i couldn't have gone
that far because i
i was so thirsty i i literally are you
right on the water line you said yeah
gotcha
oh hey here he is you found him look at
this idiot
where was he way over here in the far
corner
literally area where are you at wade
over here he was way over there by the
edge what was he doing
yeah i don't know some kind of idiot
that's not even close to a direction
where you would go
if you were drowning and needed they're
dying of thirst my orientation from the
bears house to the boat
to the outer ocean instead of accurate
but your location was stupid well yes
but
i i i'm not proud of this moment i'm not
proud
you should no i could just leave you
somewhere i don't have to bring you to a
bed
i have not been i've been perfectly
cordial i admit my mistakes
all right all right well you should kind
of you shouldn't be talking to the mayor
this way
you're not the mayor just because you
died near the mayor's house no you
didn't even die near the mayor's house
you died closer to the goat
that's true it would have been much more
convenient if you just died near the
mirror
the thing is i am actually yeah take a
nap
the mirror is okay oh my god look at our
beautiful goat baby
look at our beautiful girls look there's
no grass in this corner
bow to your mayor i will
oh my god you see i hate
everything about this do you see
the truth do you have to point are you
doing that
i'm pointing at our future how do you
how do you point is that part of the
mayor is this
comes with the territory oh my god i
point us towards our destiny
you're still wearing flippers listen
don't try to mock me do you hear how
we're
cackling at you i'm barely even laughing
i'm listening
like a demon over here
i'll show you a cackling
well look at me i'm the man walking
around his [ __ ] flippers like he's
four years old
the sound needs to be more prevalent
with the flam flank plant flamp
as daylight death approach we need to
get some more food but i need to find
more puffer fish look at me i'm the
mayor i
am the mayor i'm some kind of
[ __ ] no i am not
oh this is me the mayor talking this is
how i talk
who's putting who's putting hinges in
weird places
who's putting you just put an ingot
there i'm sorry is that not metal
all right i'll just calm down metal
is only metal that isn't the metal that
we want bob
duh okay fine scrap i can say things too
okay calm down mr mayor realized
i changed it to scrap calm down
the puffers respawn good i did a really
good job fighting those last time i'm
probably ready for this
leftovers do not go in this container
it's in the poop container behind oh my
god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
mark what are you rambling about like a
psychopath the poop container
is what that means nothing to me it's
where the bible goes
what it hurt me but it was dead i won
well you shouldn't touch the teeth on a
dead shark
we've all learned a valuable lesson dude
there's infinite explosives
what there's the puffers they come back
we can keep
getting puffers but do we need infinity
yes we gotta catch the chicken we gotta
catch the pig
we gotta where there's another barrel
bob found i don't know
i thought you said we needed another one
bob did you not i thought you said we
need another one i was asking
oh i think there's something wrong with
wade
get a little man i think wade's getting
ocean madness yeah
no no no no you guys understand me
you know i
i think i am starting to understand when
yeah we understand perfectly
battery charger we should get that for
sure definitely
battery charger can be connected to fuel
pipes
we need more titanium but it has
titanium
we need one more piece of titanium i had
to use one to research i only got four
mark you need to make an oxygen tank to
go with your flippies and get some more
of this [ __ ] down here here take him
i'm not at the boat take this take it
away
wait wait take him um wade take them
this is awkward okay i know which one of
us is which
i know we've been and friends to you for
a while now but
i thought what do i do with these you
got to put them on
you got to go down wade what do you want
to follow the penis the bike
i know it's not what you wanted to hear
especially from me but it's the sad
truth of the matter cool story but
we are very close to better charger we
just need to find what am i going down
for
the scrap metal and i was hoping i don't
i don't know how to find titanium mark
found titanium i thought down there
i got it from the mayor's chest when you
guys found the mayor's key i was like i
opened it up and there was
titanium in there get away ah oh
well is embarrassing this is awkward i
mean it's more awkward you don't know
your friends apart from each other but
shut up bob he knows who we are yeah
whatever i'm gonna go build a treehouse
did you guys zipline everywhere
by the way on a serious note just sorry
to break it up probably not
i don't know no i doubt it did you you
went to the zipline one time it was to
look for your unconscious body okay
bob you went to the infirmary yes yes
yeah you got all this
have okay you got the sap so let me
there's got to be another place here
that we haven't zipped
to i'm going back to mayor's house
you're cutting out a lot so you sound
drunk as well
like i said i mean that's all i said so
it's really okay that's good
yep mark did you have no flowers planted
currently
no okay well then everything's
hard no don't worry everything's fine
and that's not
real it's fine what it's you got lots of
flowers buddies no
problems oh yeah that's they're fine but
they take my flowers
i i couldn't imagine how what would
happen to flowers and such an
upstanding ship as this
we don't have any flower seeds
no we had seeds i think i've kept
planning
uh nope yeah we get back mark i really
want to talk to you about your
horrible system what's wrong with my
system
name one thing you'll you know what i
will point it out to you wait do you
have
the critiques for mark's system i do
mark is a genius he gets back here we
are really good
one thing i feel like it's
better to have this talk face to face
oh my god mark that sounds so serious
this is pretty serious i've never heard
him speak to you guys breaking up
yeah bob what happened come on be nice i
wouldn't i wouldn't know
no not you wade oh right he wouldn't
know you morons
yeah that's what i say you say that's
what i he says all the time
that smart funny guy
he's lost so much weight thank you
people don't point that out enough
do your laugh that cures cancer bob
well now i don't want to come on no do
it on command i command you oh no no i
was gonna do it but uh
who put beets and watermelon seeds in
ingots well i saw that i did nothing
about it
i don't know that no
mark um oh wait what is this
what is this what yeah so now you're
starting to see this system maya
you're starting to see the system i had
questions about huh
i think you're starting to see the
problems i was having
yeah who yeah who did it wait so what's
happening i thought you were just
critiquing the organizational system i
don't
why is mark losing his entire mind
yeah i wonder i wonder why what did you
do
bob innocent wait did it wade cool no
that's not right
wait how could you have done this to me
oh wow it's wade's name all over
everything
he's talking to you not me no no that's
a bit we know
the we know who would do this
who took all my goo hey wait mark did
you read this one
yeah see i wouldn't write that so you
know
that i had nothing to do with this he's
got a point
well mr mayor
yeah wade loves that [ __ ] we gotta call
it emergency meeting
how do we do that i'm calling it put a
wood plank in the
scraps why is there a purifier here
where's my explosive powder i crafted
okay i want to point that out today
please
[Music]
mark i feel like you're being a little
dramatic what's happening
someone stole all my my explosive powder
and i uh
it was not living for it in the fronds
why is there a watermelon oh nobody
knows what fronds are
so it's not watermelon do you mean that
there's a watermelon in the hashtag
blame wades
wait mark did you read this one this
one's pretty funny i bet everyone would
laugh at this one
come read this this must be you know
what maybe i want to take credit for
this that's pretty funny right
go home i'm gonna go home we are home
this is where you live go home i gotta
go i'm gonna go
no man my mom is calling me inside i
gotta go
nah we're gonna go home now like someone
is continually moving seeds into random
spots
i'm finding scenes everywhere i'm
looking for this explosive powder
here's your here's your exposure but for
serious
i only did a little bit i did i don't
know what you're on
everywhere all right how can i make this
better mark
tell me man this is a sweep net is not
shoulder it's not weighed no okay
wait a minute i'm with you on a lot of
this
sweep that knob being shoulder is the
most arbitrary
and capricious [ __ ] i've ever heard it's
not shoulder i didn't make a tools chest
yet
sweep net is not shoulders where we
really broke them
that's that this looks like bob
what looks like bob [ __ ] major tom it
looks like bob
no it doesn't wait where is he down by
the stairs
oh actually he's pretty cool i'll take
that come up here to the kitchen table
let's sit down and talk about
this okay you can fix my chair
okay that's not very conducive to us
having conversations
you got a bottle on your face you can't
talk to the mayor that way
okay fine hang on and move my chair now
talk to me well i spent
so much time on the organizational
system and you just
ruined everything okay what what did i
ruin by changing the names half of which
were jokes to begin with they were
jokes it was appropriate naming systems
what was the joke about planks scraps
those were fine those were fine what was
your stones
what was useful about head shoulders
knees and toes
was literally heads sure sure
we're having a counseling session okay
counsel but do our animals need water
uh the goat seems happy so far i don't
know i need
water there's water and grass can you
guys counsel and look at my our new pet
no no okay okay mark if i apologize
how would that make you feel better okay
i'll keep that on the table
if you apologize to me how would that
make you me feel why would i apologize
to you
uh i just trying to gauge where you're
at emotionally how would it make me feel
i need an answer
bad it would make me feel bad if you
apologize to me you feel bad
i don't really we're talking about me
right now don't be so shellfish mark
well on a scale of one to ten one being
you just had a satisfying poop and ten
being you haven't [ __ ] for a week
how are you feeling emotionally right
now seven
seven yeah yeah you you're oh you're
halfway through the week okay
and uh so if i give you the emotional
x-lax of an apology
will you go take this dump and leave
this
a ridiculous reaction in the past it's
not a ridiculous reaction
okay this is totally fine fine reaction
will you let it go okay
okay i am sorry
that your stupid naming system offended
me
breaking everything i'm gonna break
everything where's my hair
no no no no okay that was the wrong
approach that was the wrong
approach hang on one minute no no no no
i'm gonna break it let's go back to the
counseling chairs
understand what you're talking about
everything that i contributed
that is gone it's gone goodbye
you i'm i built those i literally just
built
those ten minutes ago take the engines
to
i actually don't know what resources it
took to build the edges
i built them i'll take it back i'll
build my own wrap
it's going to be baby oh all right there
you go
yeah engine engine gun
feel better yeah the where the nets
don't work on the pigs
oh i feel better oh are you over this
nonsense then
it's not nonsense but i'm going over
this sense
yeah thank you and i'm i'm over it
everything's even
okay why well i guess we don't need as
much fuel now
well i don't think the boat's gonna move
what makes you say that uh you need
two for the size of this uh
i'll get the right one on it cap i'm
gonna get i'll get there if you could
just destroy some more blocks around
here i might have a spare engine laying
around in my ass
pigs don't have meat oh wait did you
pick it up
maybe oh hey shark
uh you can't just place it down no it
doesn't fit back in the hole i think
maybe there's something in the water
underneath us obstructing it i think
maybe we need to weigh
anchor and uh move a little bit i don't
know if we're going to be able to move
we can [ __ ] we got sails we can shimmy
that's true
all right i'll raise anchor
wait now hold on anchor it was raised i
just
i just raised it i just raised it all
right raising anchor
guys let's get off this god forsaken
rock
we are away hey
um maybe maybe a reconsideration meeting
is in in order can i
we right we set aside our differences
i yeah but don't set aside your weight
yeah well
oh yeah i got to remove the weeds i'll
get a better organizational system
that's fine that's good that's a good
step maybe do that before you leave so i
can get these bees
what i'm not on the boat you know
i don't know why you're always obsessed
about how everything affects you
did you hear what mark just went through
yeah all right let's see if i can put
this engine back the bees
i think everything's going to be just oh
fine oh god hey there we go
hey ah the fuel jumped out of it though
that's unfortunate
okay we got plenty of biofuel we got
lots of biofuel we're actually
loaded to the tits with biofuel we just
need we do need to get more flowers
eventually
power those bad boys up let's go to an
island get some flowers
guys i'm not there
you hear something no not really oh no
wait are you doing all right no i'm not
on the boat
that doesn't sound like a problem can
you give us engines
good friends yeah yeah you got a cabin
on it well
i'm in the water
oh the shark is oh my god did he
did he somehow hey we have a chicken oh
somebody did some great work
capturing the chicken cool chicken am i
muted
all right activate engine engines on we
are away
all right whoa
[Music]
you